a openi conseguiu de novo eles lançaram
fizeram lançamento antes do lançamento
do Google simplesmente para abafar o
caso eles fizeram a mesma coisa também
quando eles lançaram o Sora então bom
eles conseguiram de novo porque o que
eles lançaram realmente é capaz de mudar
completamente como a gente vê e utiliza
Inteligência Artificial e nesse vídeo eu
vou te mostrar Porquê aqui você já tá na
página inicial você tá vendo a página
inicial aqui que introduz ao GPT for All
até inicialmente eu achei que era um
trocadilho para ser para todos né um GPT
para todo mundo mas não ele significa
Omni o que que tá acontecendo aqui é que
eles treinaram um modelo que consegue
não só compreensão de textos mas
consegue ser treinado em vídeo e também
em áudio e isso fez com que ele
desbancar qualquer outra ia que procura
ser multimodal então hoje o GPT ou ou
GPT 40 ou o GPT 4 o ele é muito mais
avançado que todas outras I todos os
outros modelos que tentam competir de
forma multimodal ou seja tentar fazer
várias coisas ao mesmo tempo o GPT 4 não
fazia já isso Alan fazia só que para ele
fazer isso ele tinha que transcrever
quando você mandava um áudio ele tinha
que modificar isso para texto mandar
para se processar e daí mandar de novo
para texto para daí transformar de novo
em áudio e o que essa tecnologia nova
esse novo llm esse novo modelo que eles
lançaram basicamente consegue fazer isso
de forma Nativa e faz com que seja muito
rápido inclusive tendo capacidade de
conversação de voz em tempo real ou seja
você consegue conversar com ma ia sem
ser ter aquele delay chato sem demorar
você consegue falar com ela em tempo
real e o que é mais incrível que eu
achei aqui também é que eles foram
capazes de melhorar aqui a comunicação
em múltiplas linguagens foram mais de 50
idiomas que Eles resolveram fazer aqui
uma coisa chamada tokenização e talvez O
mais incrível de tudo isso é que eles
estão
disponibilizando essa esse novo modelo
de graça e sinceramente quando eles
disponibilizam esse modelo de graça eu
já sei o que vem por aí Possivelmente
eles vão lançar em breve uma nova um
novo modelo pago e é por isso que eles
estão fazendo de graça mas não só isso
eu vou contar mais no final do vídeo
porque que eles estão fazendo de graça
não existe almoço grátis e você vai
descobrir o porquê mas olha só que legal
agora agora de graça as pessoas vão
poder utilizar ah a Store né que seria a
aqui essa loja aqui onde tem todos os os
modelos todos os gpts inclusive muitas
vezes eu compartilhei aqui gpts com os
meus alunos compartilhei gpts lá no meu
Instagram inclusive se você não me segue
lá no Instagram Me acompanha lá lá
normalmente onde eu compartilho as
coisas que acontecem mais rápido e que
acontece a galera que não pagava o Plus
não tinha acesso ao GPT agora todos os
usuários vão ter acesso a loja gpts
então você vai poder criar gpts por
exemplo vender um GPT para um cliente
ele não precisa ter uma conta Plus ele
vai poder utilizar dentro do limite dele
específico a aqui a versão do GPT isso
até levantou uma bandeira inclusive lá
no Twitter se você olhar tem muitas
pessoas perguntando para Open tá E aí
mas por que que eu vou pagar então o
Plus se agora todo mundo tem acesso a
ele e aqui que tá a questão se você
pagar como eu pago aqui para ter acesso
você tem acesso no plus a cinco vezes
mais mensagens e Eu posso te garantir al
mas eu nunca eu nunca cheguei no limite
de mensagens você nunca chegou porque
nunca foi tão útil aqui usarlo chat GPT
Quanto é utilizar com gpts então todos
os meus alunos que começam a utilizar
muitos gpts eles rapidamente acabam
perdendo os limites né de de mensagens
por quê Porque isso vira extremamente
útil aqui você vai ter gpts para todas
as atividades do seu dia a dia você vai
poder utilizar por exemplo análise de
dados fazer análise de planilhas de
relatórios inclusive eh uma feature que
ele tem é que ele consegue criar
relatórios em tempo real para nós de
forma de imagens Então isso é muito
legal e aqui tem muitos gpts que são
incríveis mas deixa eu voltar aqui para
o que que você vai ter acesso com ele
você vai ter acesso ao GPT considerado
hoje como mais inteligente vai ter que
conseguir utilizar a parte do Del de
criação de imagens e tudo mais fazer
upload de imagens e outra coisa que é
incrível aqui é que ao fazer upload de
imagens esse modelo aqui comprovadamente
é o modelo mais avançado que existe para
isso se eu abrir aqui ó essa outra guia
deixa eu mostrar para vocês o que que
acontece aqui Aqui tem uma demonstração
que seria de evaluation seria uma
avaliação sobre como o GPT o 4 o ele se
diferencia de todos os outros se você
olhar aqui ele é esse Rosinha aqui ele
tá acima Praticamente em todos os testes
ele vence então ele venceu no primeiro
teste no segundo teste tem um testezinho
só aqui ó que é esse drop F1 que ele
perdeu pro GPT 4 agora todos os outros
ele ganhou disparado ganhou disparado
como melhor aqui do closer nesse aqui
ele perdeu por dois dois pontinhos 0.2
pontinhos mas tirando isso ele tá muito
à frente e aqui é interessante que a
comparação não é só com a os modelos de
texto eles fizeram testes também de
áudio então se você pegar aqui por
exemplo o Whisper que também é da op ele
consegue aqui ó quanto menor quanto mais
baixo melhor ele é esse laranjinha aqui
mais fraco Ele tá muito mais rápido isso
aqui é a latência né o tempo que demora
PR para ser processado ele tá muito mais
rápido que o Whisper V3 que é a versão 3
do Whisper que é a tecnologia da Open
eye para transcrever né textos para
áudios para textos a a parte de
performance de áudio dele também quando
comparado aqui ó com a meta e o Google
você vai ver que ele tá muito melhor
olha sempre acima chegando pouquinho
acima só do Gemini mas ainda acima então
ele ganhou também em todos se a gente
vai aqui pro e o exame de zero shot
prompt que basicamente é quando você
pede só uma atividade para iar né só dar
um comando sem dar muito parâmetro
realização para ela ele também superou o
GPT 4 aqui ó em 100% dos Testes em
diversos idiomas diferentes porque como
eu falei uma das coisas incríveis que
eles fizeram aqui foi tokenizar aqui ó
language tokenization eles tokenizar e
eu posso explicar um pouco mais sobre
isso outro vídeo mas basicamente isso
permite que a gente consiga utilizar
agora com menos tokens ou seja gastando
menos a gente consegue fazer a ia
processar mais a i trabalhar melhor teve
línguas Por exemplo essa aqui que foi
4.4 vezes menos tokens utilizados ou
seja ficou não 4.4 vezes mais barato mas
tem mais uma questão aqui além disso
eles também baixaram o custo em 50% de
da utilização dessa nova desse novo
modelo ou seja ele ficou ainda mais
barato mesmo além da organização ele
ainda ficou mais barato com o desconto e
duas vezes mais rápido então tá incrível
realmente E se a gente vai pra parte de
divisão eu até fiz um teste lá para quem
me acompanha no Instagram viu eu
comparei as fotos de várias mulheres
para e a foto do meu bebê para iar
descobrir quem era a mãe e acertou
depois eu pedi para ela analisar e até
posso mostrar aqui para vocês vai ser
bem legal deixa eu pegar aqui já vou
mostrar isso para vocês agora aqui está
aqui usando já o aplicativo deles outra
novidade deles também é essa eles TM um
aplic ativo para Mac e eu consegui ter
acesso a esse aplicativo aqui está deixa
eu pegar aqui a Prom ajuda da
conversa olha só que legal
aqui aqui eu fiz todo um uma análise
para ele conseguir descobrir basicamente
com quem quem era minha esposa né ou
quem que é a mãe do bebê aí que eu
mandei para ele lá foto e ele ele
conseguiu me trazer aqui uma conclusão
eu mandei mais fotos e ele conseguiu
concluir que era e eu falei que ele
acertou Além disso eu mandei lá foto
várias fotos minhas da minha esposa e
também ah do nosso filho e ele conseguiu
também descobrir qual que era as
porcentagens de cada um né que ele criou
um relatório aqui com as porcentagens e
ficou bem legal também então a
capacidade dele se você vai comparar
aqui nos testes de visão é absurda ele
dá um pau em todo mundo ele ganha de
todo mundo ele ganha do GPT 4 ele ganha
do geminii ele ganha do clou Opus então
ele tá incrível e muito mais barato
depois eu vou mostrar a diferença de
preço de um pro outro talvez o que eu
achei mais incrível ainda foi a o tempo
de resposta dele com áudio se você
entrar aqui no YouTube da op tem vários
exemplos e eu separei alguns aqui para
vocês esse
aqui basicamente ele vai mostrar a
capacidade em tempo real
como é multimodal ele CONSEG olhar o que
tá acontecendo e responder em tempo real
o que tá acontecendo Então el tá
mostrando o ambiente e faz uma pergunta
e ela consegue responder na hora outro
que eu gostei bastante também eles
mostram vários tons várias
Emoções aqui eles vão pedindo várias
formas diferentes da
comunicar ele quer mais dramático e ele
vai pedindo mais drama mais drama mais
drama e ela vai ficando mais
dramática outro exemplo também bem
interessante aqui que a gente tem é aqui
onde ele colocou duas já eu já fiz isso
inclusive na minha casa tá eu coloquei
dois chat APT para conversar mas foi
meio chato porque eles demorava muito
tempo para responder um ao outro e olha
só a velocidade Olha a entonação da voz
utilizada ó ele pausou a primeira né
para não ouv isso Que loucura né eu não
tinha visto esse vídeo todo
aqui ó em tempo real tá visualizando ele
falando e diferente inclusive dos vídeos
dos lançamentos do Google tudo que eles
fizeram lá foi no palco e mostraram em
tempo real mesmo funcionando que legal
uma das ias então um dos celulares está
utilizando a câmera e vai poder
conversar sobre isso que tá visualizando
enquanto ele conversa com
outro
olha ó descreveu o
cara para quem não sabe ISS aqui ele é
um dos fundadores da Open ele é um meio
que co com Olha que legal ela tá fazendo
perguntas para a outra EA poder
descrever mais com base na
câmera Então os dois estão conversando
as duas estão conversando em tempo real
ou seja sem delay sobre o que o out tá
vendo é uma loucura Isso aqui é uma
loucura e avança ah não tá disponível já
essa conversação em tempo real ainda não
ainda não está disponível mas o que está
disponível para vocês Inclusive tem um
vídeo aqui no canal é você já poder uar
o app oficial da openi no seu Mac por
enquanto é disponível apenas para Mac já
tem um vídeo aqui no canal mostrando
como utilizar mas eu quero que vocês
entendam uma coisa tudo isso aqui que a
gente tá vendo Inclusive tem outros
vídeos aqui que são até digamos h mais
próximos disso aqui é a gente tá se
aproximando muito de uma tecnologia de
um filme que se você não assistiu ainda
eu aconselho a assistir que é o her que
é um filme que mostra um pouquinho dessa
interação entre voz em tempo real com
inteligência com seres humanos então eh
a o que que tu acredita que muda agora
quero falar um pouquinho sobre as coisas
que eu acredito que começam a mudar a
partir daqui a Open já tava meio que
namorando abrir mais digamos assim o seu
leque ético vamos dizer que é o quê eles
estavam já H com alguns projetos até
mesmo de parcerias com empresas que
estavam desenvolvendo namoradas ias isso
tem tweets mostrando isso se você
pesquisar e com essa tecnologia vai ser
possível criar realmente o que teve esse
filme aqui esse filme Se eu não me
engano é de 2009 2011 deixa eu ver aqui
ó 13 2013 esse filme ou seja 11 anos
atrás Esse filme foi lançado e ele tá
retratando basicamente o que a gente vai
vive agora e se você quiser entender eu
aconselho a assistir esse filme O que
mais Alan Tu acredita aí que vai
acontecer a partir de agora a gente
tendo o GPT 4 disponível para todas as
pessoas ainda não está mas em breve vai
ser ah a gente vai ter uma uma maior
inserção de pessoas que realmente vão
poder experienciar o poder da ia então
muita gente fica cética porque vai lá
Testa o o chat abt 3.5 é uma bosta e diz
que ya não funciona agora todo mundo vai
poder ter acesso a isso aqui poder ter
uma aa de ponta e essa é uma grande
transformação que a openi tá trazendo
que é poder possibilitar que pessoas
comuns através de um celular tenam
acesso a melhor o melhor modelo
disponível e Isso muda completamente
tudo porque agora você pode ah
introduzir e a para pessoas que antes
não queriam pagar $2 para ter os
melhores modelos então isso quebra uma
barreira gigantesca que gente tinha PR
as pessoas poderem começar a utilizar
grandes modelos isso vai fazer com que
as pessoas tenham mais produtividade e
cada vez mais interajam e e fiquem por
dentro do mercado de i e isso vai com
certeza fomentar muito o mercado de ia
inclusive para fazer esse vídeo para
você entender como é boa essa Iá Ah eu
tinha eu peguei alguns vídeos americanos
aqui para ver o que que eles tinham
resumido eu pedi pro cre escrevi na hora
aqui esse prompt para que o cloud que é
Opus que ele é extremamente caro Se eu
for botar aqui o pricing Se eu colocar
aqui a comparação Olha só então Esse
site é bem legal para vocês poderem
comparar e tudo mais ah a janela de
contexto ainda é maior Mas se a gente
vai para cá pro preço Olha só o preço de
de dados quando eu envio é 15 no Opus e
no GPT 4 é $5 o de saída é $5 e aqui é
$1 ou seja o o Closure TR ele é três
vezes mais caro de dados de entrada e
cinco vezes mais caro para d de saída ou
seja cinco vezes mais caro só que se a
gente vai olhar pra comparação aqui dos
Testes Olha só o GPT 4 ganha ganhou aqui
e ele ganhou aqui também então ele tá
melhor que o Opus sendo extremamente
cinco vezes mais mais barato por exemplo
então é ridículo e eu resolvi testar
isso na prática eu peguei aqui pedi para
ele fazer ele fez aqui para nós
um uma pauta né para esse vídeo que a
gente tá aqui e eu fiz vou fazer o
seguinte em tempo real aqui com vocês eu
vou abrir o app novo app da Open vou
clicar aqui option espaço abrir o app
vou clicar aqui vou selecionar os
arquivos que eu baixei com a transcrição
daqueles vídeos carreguei vou colar o
mesmo prompt e vamos ver o que vai
acontecer em tempo real colei aqui e ele
tá aqui carregando para mim fazendo para
mim agora uma pauta para esse vídeo aqui
que a gente tá gravando ó Apresente o
contexto introdução sobre opi tópicos
principais lançamento capacidade de
conversação em tempo real acessibilidade
e gratuitidade que eu falei né ele vai
ser gratuito funções divisões análise de
dados assistente pessoal em Real Time
uma coisa que eu não falei tanto para
vocês aqui mas assim a grande mudança
que tá trazendo aqui é essa capacidade
você vai ter um GPT 4 esse GPT 4 o vai
tá ali que nem tá aqui nesse app esse
App ainda não está com a versão dele de
Real Time ainda vão disponibilizar isso
ou seja dessa dessa dessa capacidade de
ver Inclusive a tela em tempo real Mas
em breve vai ser disponibilizado e
quando isso acontecer cara sua
produtividade vai ser animal o s autman
utilizou durante uma semana ele falou
que foi incrível quanto velocidade ele
tem e ele vai continuar utilizando isso
no dia a dia dele aplicações futuras
aqui ó ele me trouxe aqui o falar sobre
as aplicações futuras Olha como ficou
mais completo tá vamos comparar aqui ó
Isso aqui foi o da Opus que é muito mais
caro muito muito mais caro Olha só como
ficou melhor a pauta para esse vídeo
aqui esse vídeo teria ficado ainda
melhor se eu tivesse feito isso aqui ah
utilizando aqui por exemplo o jaat PT 4
o
aqui comparação com a concorrência ele
falou aqui ó mostrar que enquanto o
Google lançou o 1.5 pro pode dar com a
janela de contexo até 2 milhões ele
ainda se destaca porque tem um
desempenho melhor e aqui ele vai
mostrando inclusive aqui ó Inserir a um
meme sobre a careca do olhar para
descobrir e tudo mais fez várias coisas
aqui as sugestões de inserção de visuais
humorísticas estruturação visual do
vídeo ele mostrou como fazer o vídeo
olha só no final ele falou assim ó
apresentador refletindo sobre o futuro
para uma chamada para ação será Será que
eu faço isso agora para concluir o vídeo
Então como vocês podem ver aqui ficou
muito muito muito muito muito melhor
utilizar o GPT ou que é muito mais
barato também então assim a openi tá de
parabéns eu não esperava tanto eu eu nem
falei sobre tudo que é possível fazer
aqui não falei sobre Ah todas as
possibilidades futuras que isso vão
trazer isso eu vou deixar para outro
vídeo esse vídeo já tá ficando longo se
você gostou desse tipo de vídeo aqui
então já deixa um like aí se inscreve no
canal eu nunca peço para vocês isso
porque eu nem ah nem faço muito vídeo
para vocês mas pretendo começar a fazer
então se você quer ficar por dentro que
tá acontecendo com vídeos mais
frequentes nessa pegada onde
simplesmente eu abro minha tela e mostro
para vocês as coisas então comenta aqui
se você gostou e deixa eu terminar agora
com uma reflexão sobre o futuro como ele
pediu ali Será que isso aqui pode ser o
começo que a gente precisa para atingir
ai bom a gente se vê aqui nos próximos
vídeos